hey guys hey what's gonna we're coming
up with a Zombie Survival Plan Cam's
done some science and he reckons we're
doomed yeah you see I crunched the
numbers and it turns out the odds of a
zombie apocalypse 32.3 3% repeating of
course well I mean that's better than we
usually get that crack okay I need to
stock up on some tinned food tinned food
you're not gonna need tinned food when
there's gonna be a dead guy Naurang at
your own course what we need is like
weapons and junk
I've got weapons and I've got junk well
I prefer if it was some kind of katana
or something well I want something with
impact you know like got a rifle or
shotgun that's too loud see I prefer the
ancient Egyptian capiche
it's quiet smooth and stylish and a
weapon used by the Pharaohs we're not
gonna call you Pharaoh
okay can you just stop asking there's
only one way to settle this video games
wait what game we play dying light oh
yeah cool the actual definitive answer
what is the best way to kill zombies in
the event of the inevitable zombie
attack if the answer is to be me right
now I think it's punching you definitely
the owner of a lot of Lucy's bullets
right well there's gonna be friendly
fire in the apocalypse so shoot me
though this is London right and we don't
have a lot of guns in London this
doesn't look like London's I mean this
is it this is science we're doing this
the sly and more like a different
country altogether all right this way
okay which way we run it's a bit like
baseball back to the face I've never
actually used a sword in real life I'll
be honest my using my ability to carve
people is ideal I feel incredible I
think the Egyptians knew what they were
doing because this cottage is fantastic
guys are no good though because they
don't have heads if he dead
well he has a thing on his back oh well
he exploded I some not gonna lie I've
been bitten what if they do keep being
really nice things up yeah it blows up
your good friend set things right I'm
saving you both there's one and the
other okay thanks all right I guess it's
just a minor setback I really I really
just wanted to hit someone in the face
and say that's not cricket but Yoshi she
saved her salty friend by diving in
front of the flying sword in the zombie
apocalypse follow said because the
zombies are afraid of people you know
what's hitting the cat people who use
guns in a zombie apocalypse but I am
doing really well I think maybe I killed
all of them don't worry guys were save
the planet all right I found one don't
worry
oh no I got loads of here like I said I
know who would like to come and save her
life with their best friend said I think
your book that this is your best way to
go well no wait there's really not
taking ten seconds to say Brian well I
think we're all dead
the point is we killed a lot of zombies
I did
so we're just gonna die regardless wow
that is such a bummer I never did finish
that pyramid and only got one wife well
I guess we just weren't supposed to
survive the apocalypse Seafarer that's
kind of the point of the apocalypse why
do you still have that speedy getaway
there there boy we'll see you next week
hate zombies
don't cams hey guys hey didn't we leave
now today have you don't ever have a cat
you understand me don't you boy
no don't stop come on you hungry girl so
lunch it thought they liked it when
stroked the horn